the biggest problem is you're right
you're climbing up a hill that isn't
going to be valuable when you get there
it's super-super not interesting to each
ship for the next seven years get there
and be like fry oh that's exactly what's
gonna happen
[Music]
[Music]
really good
don't worry about this is easy do you
guys mean neat awesome so tell me what
you guys are up to link goes fast man
it took me two years to find out to like
just deep decompress from that
we can redirect into 30 for 30 that is
our Atlanta
their technicians you met a sacrament in
that way yeah it's a living film
television star trying to figure on
we started to figure that at the same
time
I mean the the biggest problem is you're
right you're climbing up a hill that
isn't gonna be valuable when you get
there it's super-super not interesting
to each ship for the next seven years
get there and be like fry oh that's
exactly what's gonna happen right so
you're like okay let's not do that
like there was a part of his life just
just disappeared
got it yep do all the things that I want
to do and he's got me I realize that's
just not who you are we also young as
[ __ ] yo travel I think I do have
something to say so I'm trying to
we can pack the transformer sports
content
started to get exciting for me and then
we're starting to actually take the step
to make films
CDs or something so I think
to learn
that's right now
initially starts around
it's blogs
[Music]
I mean yes yeah build the leverage and
then decide where you want to put all
that attention whether it's through
something like you know your version of
the ESPN barstool or players Tribune
mixed with its head and really wherever
you take it and I think if you can spend
a year 18 months building up your
personal brand creating content exactly
how you said it whether the blog and the
podcasts are the main pillars or the
podcast on a blog surround it with other
stuff and then really read the tea
leaves and see who's reaching out to you
from your first chapter of your life
who's emerging and interested in this
new chapter it's funny learn cheaply
must make mistakes at low costs but more
importantly gather enormous amounts of
quantity quant and qual feedback that
you know and the other thing is also
recognizing in 24 months there may be a
slight spin on it that you don't know
yet or taste yet where it's literally
one story from one you know one former
teammate or somebody else or a guy or a
kid on the street that stops you that
could end up becoming the anchor of the
framework I still so the thing with the
blog that I would tell you is super
important to me as the first thing about
this meaning you need to go fast there
are still not famous people really
blogging yeah the same reason Ashton
one's so big on Twitter the same reason
Khaled won on snapchat there's not a lot
of if you know I don't know
babban I'm not really paying it I'm so
busy but like I don't feel like there's
definitely there's no athlete of your
caliber that I can think of that is
vlogging for real
yeah I mean I'm super close with
maverick and all that but that's that's
that's not him on YouTube with no
subscribers at first being like hey like
like really doing it that's [ __ ]
crazy and then again all these
characters like like all these
characters when you're actually famous
and you actually play basketball I mean
like half the vloggers that are doing
well like will reach out I mean talking
like the Paul Brothers and all these
crazy characters that I know them
sitting there being like it's Steve Nash
actually vlogging on YouTube
followed by holy [ __ ] let's reach out to
him and do like a three-point contest in
my backyard is like insane especially in
LA they're all like people overthink it
they think if the first episode isn't
right they can't mess up like like oh
you know the the ideal tweet is like
holy [ __ ] I listen to Steve Nash's first
podcast it sucked
episode 17 with Antoine Walker how he
lost all his mother money is insane you
can't lose the only the only way you can
lose is by not recognizing how few
people that look like you have done it
and then letting two of them I mean
everybody's having this conversation
like everybody kind of knows something's
going on
we are
it's not a boxset right does not get
this it's not gonna go you just want to
keep connecting this is not a game one
by the way Star Wars is one it's not
special effects it's just not it's not
the game we're playing what's cool about
it is if you do this game right you have
unlimited ability to do Star Wars if you
want it's like true family I was pumped
when you said can I bring my guy I'm
like perfect I'm bringing Nate this is
not a joke at some point in the last 18
months or so or two years ago or three
years ago Nate's like there's three
people I need you to become friends with
Steve Nash John Mayer and Phil Mickelson
and this is not a joke I've become
friends with all three this year it was
the craziest well then
no pleasure in such as my job everybody
have a great holiday Manjit guys bye
take care
great meeting with Steve Nash what a
great [ __ ] dude love meeting like
dudes that are awesome getting towards
the end of the year vlog super excited
to see what the team does for you guys
in these two weeks that I'm away you got
stuff that I got some stuff just
wrapping up the year getting a bunch of
contract sign for 2018 vaynermedia is
looking real real real good coming out
the gate hard with a new book on the
30th excited about that got a bunch of
conferences agent 2021 big event in
Houston Super Bowl Boehner sports party
Cub weeks later and be a all-star
weekend being her sports party got a new
- new sneakers coming out the oh three
oh four but predominantly 96% Vayner X
pure Wow vaynermedia real hardcore focus
for me next year excited about it
genuinely excited about next year male
show that part I want to hear it all the
comments ahead so here so so here's
here's what we're gonna have to figure
out right even though I feel the way you
about you that I felt with my wife I'm
gonna need a couple months of us jamming
right I also want to know them a little
bit so what we need to think about is I
hear you loud and clear and I love the
way you're talking about it I need to
figure out the vibes we need to figure
out how there's so much good here right
like there's so many ways to slice this
I need to be thoughtful of like I gotta
feel comfortable and then I can go fast
you know what I mean
[Music]
how you doing brother how are you you
look insane I mean I see it I see it
online but to see it in person just
makes me so [ __ ] happy
[Music]
funny thing happens when you speak the
truth
yeah you know yeah when you speak the
truth with no expectation or wants and
returns and mine's not like religious or
altruistic Minds more predicated on my
ability to get mine and being brought up
in a way that my mom and I were talking
about this the other day
I'm just like we're so similar I'm so
similar to my mom and a lot of raising
that I've got certain things of my dad
and that's how I become me we don't want
anything from anybody
everything's our fault we're very
insular I know man the best part is when
you get to interact with somebody you
know like there's millions of people
eventually I'll never know but to your
point of 8 years just like all I was
thinking about it
today on when we're gonna make it happen
just think about all the silly like
conversations through the years building
mixtapes and Travis Porter I always
think about those stories you know and
then just watching your whole like when
you started running like one of those
videos really caught me then you were
like ready to go and now you looking at
me people don't even recognize you I'm
sure like you roll up on people are like
what
[Laughter]
a lot man and I saw you like a month ago
you're looking like he's really training
when I was like oh hey I always want to
be Anthony I was like the big kid yep
and like I love basketball we up and
search versus skins as a kid like I'd
have to give me an assurance like if
they pick feels like I wouldn't be able
to play and then that the pool never
took my shirt so I needed something to
do that growing up so it's like when you
want you gotta have something that's you
and I was like I'm I'm CEO Charlie's
like young age I'm a CEO charlie and at
that early age I very what I truly
wanted to be and I did business and I
got good at it
and as the business grew you know like
[Laughter]
300 pounds and and this guy named Scott
Cameron came into my life the most
amazing man he said I like to see
something you butt-licker like you're
like you can't diet anymore because I
can tell like your brain is fried from
like always doing diet he said we're
gonna run so we did three marathons and
from your first marathon to the third
marathon I gained weight you don't
really yes cuz I was a binge eater
laying out words and I could run 26.2
miles but then our track and
like 10,000 calories in the night I knew
something was wrong but I didn't know
what was wrong and
when one day I woke up and the rumors
that started spinning and this is when
he was doing the dance and sweaters
their whole game yeah like I wake like
you're the top of your business game
never sad never hope wake up Luna's spin
and I'm like oh this isn't good
and then I got out of bed wait to pick
up the shoes found out woke up where on
the floor but you woke up there you got
in the hospital and with the doctor
brain tumor wrapped around left optic
nerve coronary artery you can start
corroding the top of my spinal cord at
that point is like when you gave me like
my secret sword to go slay my dragon
like I'm like imma change everything
this is the Sun mansion
I'm gonna change everything and I knew
everything had to change and I left my
company I said I'm gonna doing hiring
man and I said I'm gonna reverse this
brain tumor naturally because I'm not
doing chemo and this medication that the
doctors have me on affects your heart
bags that's when I said I'm gonna do an
Ironman and I just started going I went
vegan plant-based and reversing it
naturally terrible like my brains were
shrinking because of the food I eat I
get it brother
I believe in that [ __ ] in a real [ __ ]
way
like I did I did a hundred and twelve
mile bike ride from Atlanta to Alabama
went back and I got three I think like
30 37 episodes of daily like when I say
like what I had to change everything
else consuming not just food but like
what you consume literally like it's
like like when I say you gave me that
sword
just like slay my dragon I'm not like
taking the biggest risk of my life like
it's just like like this is scary
hell yeah okay because that's your truth
talk about eating dirt like it's like
like no you know now live before
roommates because I know like I'm smart
enough to know Elaine like okay where
I'm going I want to get a fleet that's
not just like clear like like I'm a good
businessman I've always heard that
businessman but my dream that eight year
old truth before I put all this like
society stuff on me like this mask it's
like I want to be an athlete
so I'm eating dirt I know I was gonna
die now live like so my friends yeah of
course good for me to speak
[Music]
this is my Tyrion here my grandparents
were immigrants from living and they had
your men's out not success but metallic
like immigrant like more like like
they're not worried about like like you
know like stuff oh so so the question of
the friends or acquaintances is am I
happy because I'm always working like I
think is that the basis is that the
basic happy because absolutely like that
makes a lot of sense to me that's a
that's a valid question for people that
value other things its values like
nothing makes me happier than building
nothing makes me happier than building
in a way that also builds up people
along the way as I'm building yeah I
mean listen I love working like I get it
like my big thing is that is that I
think people need to be smart about what
they say you know like to me the person
that's far more unhappy than I am is the
one that says that their CEO or they're
hustling and they're not I think I think
anybody is happy when they're living
their truth including the versa me I
think the people that are the people
that I notice that are most happy that
remind me of me are actually people that
aren't working that much that have found
their work-life balance I grew up in a
very middle class lower middle class I
have a very interesting point of
reference which is the happiest person I
saw growing up where my parents who work
like dogs
both my mom in the house my dad outside
and like random people that were like
like friends parents that were making 47
K a year and they were just like liked
drinking Budweiser and watching the game
and I kept it simple as [ __ ]
I think I think I think people find
happiness and extremes I really do I
think when you're half pregnant there's
stuck you're like something you know
that's why that's why I'm making 110
thousand a year scares me like it feels
middle honestly I'm just happy people
are talking oh yeah no and I could tell
I don't think you know listen very few
people come at me with real heat or
anger if they do they're just in a bad
place I think people just cure it listen
I'm working much harder than most people
that's just the truth and I think that
[ __ ] with people especially when I
started the blog and there became no
debate but I do that on purpose because
I think there's a lot of people honest
there's a lot of immigrants who can
outwork the competition or like back to
it where the [ __ ] are you two from you
don't need to be an immigrant like looks
a lot of people that live like
immigrants that are born here like yeah
I think I mean for me brother I'm living
my truth you know my my biggest honestly
I'm most unhappy when I'm doing the most
normal [ __ ] I'm only happy in my
extremes just living a truth man
right like the fact that you like tapped
into yourself and executed no rare that
is
people are scared to live their truth
because they're worried about all the
other variables that's why your world is
so extreme you went so hardcore both
ways it's good to see you man course man
[Music]
you
[Music]